esto me está agradecido con todos los
que mantienen la línea de defensa en
severodonezk y muestran a los ocupantes
que la paz era nuestra una frase que
marca la gravedad de la situación en el
este de ucrania a decir del mandatario
con el avance de las tropas rusas la
situación es indescriptible mente
difícil
a raíz de los ataques rusos en severo
don jets toda la infraestructura crítica
de la ciudad fue destruida el 90% de los
edificios están dañados más de dos
tercios de las viviendas residenciales
están completamente destruidas no hay
telecomunicaciones el bombardeo es
continuo pues sin coste según
autoridades ucranianas el incremento de
la ofensiva sobre severodonezk tiene el
objetivo de capturar la región oriental
de lugansk tras retirarse del norte de
ucrania moscú enfocó una segunda fase de
la llamada operación militar especial en
tomar el control del donbass con el
apoyo de los separatistas pro rusos
intenciones que fueron reiteradas por el
ministro de asuntos exteriores ruso
serguéi lávrov la liberación de las
regiones de donges y lugar reconocidas
por rusia como estados independientes es
una prioridad incondicional
según el instituto para el estudio de la
guerra los rusos no habrían logrado
rodear esta estratégica urbe severa done
y ski lysychansk son las últimas zonas
importantes bajo el control ucraniano en
la provincia de lugansk por lo que se
teme que esta zona pueda convertirse en
una nueva mariupol